of all the attractions michelle saw in
her holiday in the uk the floor of
terminal 5 was not on her list of places
to spend a night her flight was
cancelled last night minutes before
boarding there's nobody there's no
there's nobody to tell you where to go
what to do
um so people just try to find like safe
places to sleep so a lot of people will
be on benches here at the coffee shop i
got like a choice spot right here
and um people rolling on the floor
it was just crazy
heathrow airport scrapped another 30
flights this morning cues delays and
cancelled flights a cocktail of
frustration that's seemingly never
ending even for those now back home
misplaced and unclaimed bags litter some
terminals for many finding them is a
challenge helena spent her entire
holiday in lisbon without her luggage
now back in london 16 days later she
still hasn't got it it's really annoying
and it was a mix of my stuff but also my
15 month old son stuff so there's bits
in there that he just would have made
our like lives a lot easier we've done a
bit of a time total because we had to
submit it to the airline and it's just
coming under 1 000 pounds for everything
in there that you might not see again
that we might not see again
heathrow airport says it's working with
airlines to get passengers affected
today rebooked onto other flights the
transport secretary though says there's
no excuse for the disruption and wants
to streamline departure schedules and
tackle staff shortages
today i'm announcing a 22-point plan to
help recruit retain staff improve
resilience so that passengers disruption
this summer is minimized who slept in
the airport raise your hand
but the plan has been accused of being
short-sighted with not enough focus on
resourcing the industry to cope with the
pre-pandemic passenger numbers so the
government is blaming airports and
airlines they're both blaming each other
and are also angry at the government
which claims that operators have been
over selling on flights and they want
them to deliver a reliable summer
schedule but it all seems rather last
minute with school summer holidays
starting this week in northern ireland
and scotland and there's another issue
strike action
some 700 british airways workers are due
to walk out in a dispute over pay next
month a stress-free summer break seems
unlikely ashna harinag sky news